Okay.
Einfachste Erklärung, die speziell auf diejenigen unter Ihnen aus der Hochfrequenz-Informationstechnologie zugeschnitten ist.
Mit anderen Worten, die Leute, denen ich es in den letzten anderthalb Jahren vorgestellt habe, sagen: Woher wisst ihr das nicht und warum erzählt ihr anderen Leuten nicht, was COVID wirklich ist?
Es ist ein cyberphysisches Rückgrat.
Was ist das?
Was ist Telepathie?
Los geht's.
Was ist die Aura?
Du hast keine Ahnung.
Ihr, wer auch immer ihr in den Bereichen Informationstechnologie, Hochfrequenz, Computernetzwerkcode seid, Nerds mit Python, Leute.
Ich bin mit ein paar von euch aufgewachsen und mein ganzes Leben lang.
Hast du nie an irgendwas von dem Zeug geglaubt?
Chakren, wie hier hinter mir.
Das ist Foo, Foo und Woo Woo.
Und worauf konzentrierst du dich?
Übertragung von Radiofrequenzen durch den menschlichen Körper.
Durch den menschlichen Körper.
Seit 1995 durch den menschlichen Körper.
Sie müssen also zunächst verstehen, dass ich, nachdem ich Opfer von elektronischer Folter wurde und bis 2019 überhaupt nichts von der Seite der elektronischen Kriegsführung wusste, zur Post gegangen bin und dort gesagt wurde, dass Sie in den neuen 60 Jahren sind.
Und ich hatte vor langer Zeit zufällig einen Job.
Und dieses Mal werde ich dir zeigen, warum das für bestimmte Leute so ein Problem ist, weil sie sagen, leg dich nicht mit ihr an, weil sie es weiß.
Ja.
High Speed Access Corporation.
Vor dem Verkauf an Charter Communications befand sich das Network Operations Center mit drei unterirdischen Sicherheitsebenen in Louisville, Kentucky.
Der zweite von Cisco zertifizierte Netzwerkexperte war, der mit den anderen aus dem Flugzeug stieg.
Und als ich 19 Jahre alt war, ging ich im Dunkeln rüber, um diesem Herrn, der unser Network Operations Center leitete, Hallo zu sagen.
Und dann ging ich als Außendiensttechniker zurück nach Wisconsin.
Ich war einer von zwei Leuten, die den Bundesstaat Wisconsin von Dial-Up auf Breitband umgestellt haben, den Bundesstaat auf Madison, was DOCSIS war, weil es eine große Stadt ist, Milwaukee und Green Bay, Time Warner, DOCSIS-Durchgangsmodems, was auch immer.
Aber für die kleineren Städte war ich in Eau Claire, Wisconsin, stationiert.
Rice Lake war eine weitere Pflanze, für die ich verantwortlich war.
Diese Menschen in kleineren Gemeinden mussten mit der Kabelanlage für Kupfer und Glasfaser und allen Versorgungseinrichtungen für Wasser und allem anderen umgestellt werden.
Und all das ist Anlagenarchitektur, über die Hochfrequenzexperten, Linienarbeiter und Anlagentechniker alles wissen.
Okay, weißt du jetzt über das Preissystem mit der National Security Agency Bescheid und Karten?
Wissen Sie von all den geheimen Datenverbindungen, die wir mit AT&T und unseren Stingray- und Dirt-Bikes für die Funkfrequenz der lokalen Polizeicomputer verwenden?
Meine Aufgabe war es, den Kabelleuten, die die Montage und so weiter an der Stange oder zu Hause machten, zu sagen, was zu tun war, denn ich hatte die Kontrolle über das Kabelmodem im Kopf und am hinteren Ende.
Okay.
So habe ich den Menschen 2001 zur gleichen Zeit Meditation, Heilung, Berührung und das Biofeld beigebracht.
Okay, in meiner Freizeit, während ich bei Charter arbeite, um Leuten beizubringen, dass das ein Körperteil ist.
Körperteil.
Und dann stehe ich hier vor Leuten und sage: Zeig mir dein Biofeld.
Und sie sagen: Oh, das ist unmöglich.
Und ich sagte: Nein, es sind Körperteile.
Entschuldigung, ich versuche meine Beleuchtung hier zu reparieren, damit du sie sehen kannst.
Und dann stehe ich auf und sage: Lass dir die Haare zu Berge stehen.
Es heißt Pilotenerektion.
Es ist das sympathische Nervensystem.
Entschuldigung, dass ich es parasympathisch nenne.
Das ist was anderes.
Das ist Verdauung.
Nun, komm schon, lass es uns sehen.
Lass mich meine Arme bewegen.
Nichts passiert.
Ja.
Okay.
Erstens, rollen Sie Ihre Schultern nach vorne, wenn Sie auch gesessen haben.
Und wenn ich mir etwas Mühe gebe.
Schild.
Das ist dein Biofeld.
Deshalb verstehen es diejenigen von Ihnen, die es immer noch nicht verstehen.
Wie funktioniert dein Telefon?
Dein Handy.
Sag mir, wie es funktioniert.
Das war die andere Zickigkeit, die ich immer wieder von Leuten bekam.
Sie sagen, nun, alles, was du tust, ist zu sagen, wie funktioniert dein Telefon?
Nein, ich versuche, Ihre Aufmerksamkeit auf buchstäbliche technische Kennzahlen zu lenken, obwohl ich nicht weiß, wo mein Telefon geblieben ist, damit Sie verstehen, wie einfach es ist, sich bei Ihnen anzumelden und Änderungen vorzunehmen.
Wie sind wir also an diesen Punkt gekommen, an dem all diese guten Leute im Bereich Radiofrequenz usw.
nichts darüber wissen, was wir eigentlich im menschlichen Körper tun?
Und um das alles zu erklären, musste ich Unmengen von Schildern anbringen.
Ich musste immer wieder hierher zurückkehren.
Und ich habe versucht herauszufinden, warum es so ist Da ist mein Telefon, dass niemand sonst diese Dinge zu wissen scheint.
Okay.
Das ist mein toller Oncles-Ordner von der Sheppard Air Force Base.
Ich zeige oft auch seine Sachen auf dem Aberdeen Proving Ground.
Das ist mein kleines rosafarbenes Buch, wo auch immer es sich gerade versteckt.
Und dann gehe ich auch seine alten Notizen mit Flussdichte-Notation, mit Quecksilber und so weiter durch.
Warum?
Damit die Leute verstehen, dass das schon sehr lange so ist.
Also sag mir, wie dein Telefon funktioniert.
Wenn Sie auf eine Schaltfläche klicken und eine E-Mail senden.
Sie sehen nicht, dass die E-Mail das Telefon verlässt.
Es ist ein drahtloses unsichtbares Signal, genau wie Ihr Körper.
Es ist ein Körperteil.
Als ich für meinen Job bei UW Whitewater arbeitete, fand ich IBM-Software, von der sie behaupteten, dass sie auch schon vor langer Zeit verwendet wurde, als 4G in ihnen ihr Zeug zum Angriff auf das menschliche Immunsystem auf die Beine stellen wollte.
Nun, wenn Sie nicht wissen, dass das menschliche Immunsystem zu 80% Ihr Biofeld ausmacht, dann nannten Sie es Aura, Sie nannten es dämlich.
Ja, ich weiß.
Das liegt daran, dass 6000 Jahre menschlicher Telemetrie, Chiropraktik und der Rest für Ihr Kreislaufsystem einfach auf magische Weise verschwunden sind.
Niemand hat eine Ahnung, was vor sich geht.
Das waren 6000 Jahre des menschlichen Kreislaufsystems.
Du nennst es Chakren?
Ja, sie nennen es Vogelfeuer.
Vor 150 Jahren.
Aleister Crowley und Leute.
Ja.
Nichts ist real außer dem, was du sehen kannst.
Es gibt keinen Biofilm, es gibt keine Schaltpläne, es gibt keinen echten Onyx, es gibt kein Plasmonikum.
Es gibt nichts außer dem, was du sehen kannst.
Oder das ist der Körperteil, der für 80% unseres Immunsystems verantwortlich ist.
Woher wissen wir das mit Sicherheit?
Die Definition im Kinderkrankenhaus.
Die Organe und Gewebe, aus denen das Immunsystem besteht, der Thymus, das Knochenmark, das Lymphsystem, Ihre Gefäße, Ihre Milz und Ihre Haut.
Also denke ich, ja, die menschliche Biosphäre wird von Projektzellen beobachtet.
Das menschliche Biofeld ist also die Aura.
Ist dein W-Band Aid oder 2.15.6.
Richtlinie 3.000.09 des Verteidigungsministeriums.
Alles ist autonom und Sie haben eine MQ Nine Reaper-Drohne an Ihrer Haut und Ihrem Knochen befestigt.
Das ist ein großer Vogel für diejenigen von Ihnen, die wissen, dass sie riesig ist.
Also für mich frage ich mich, warum zur Hölle brauchen wir so etwas Großes?
Nun, für diejenigen unter Ihnen, die sich wieder mit Radiofrequenz beschäftigen, sie verstehen nicht, dass wir mit den Partikeln in der Atmosphäre herumspielen und das menschliche Biofeld mit dem Doppler diskutieren.
Okay.
Und wir sprechen über nichts davon.
Wir sprechen nicht über Geoengineering und darüber, ob Steuerung und all diese Systeme zusammenarbeiten.
Wenn ich mich in Ihren Körper einlogge, betrachte ich mehrere Mannigfaltigkeiten, Stiermannigfaltigkeiten, und dann verwende ich Mathematik, um mich mit etwas namens Biophysik, Optoarray, elektronische Photonik, in Ihre Zellstruktur einzuloggen, indem ich mich mit Druck, Temperatur und Physik, physikalischer Biophysik bewege.
Ändere dich nicht.
Oh, Mann, ich winke mit meinem Zauberstab.
Nein, ich logge mich direkt mit Radiofrequenz in deinen Körper ein.
So wird I Precision Health Care angeboten.
Und ich werde dir gleich das größere Schild hier zeigen.
Schritt eins Seit 2005 arbeitet jeder kleine Nerd, der seit 2005 Sigma und Bluetooth für Lichtschalter programmieren könnte, mit diesen Biosensoren K: Hot Nearest Neighbor Routing, dynamische Kanalzuweisung, thermisches dynamisches Routing genau dort.
Du kannst es nachschlagen.
Öffne den kürzesten Weg, zuerst von Körper zu Körper.
Wie habe ich es gefunden?
Cybersicherheit für die neue digitale ID im sechs G lo Personal Area Network von Maschine zu Maschine.
Kein Mensch kann es knacken oder D-verschlüsselt oder verschlüsselt und es ist Ad-hoc-Fahrzeug ad- oder ad-hoc oder was auch immer.
Und dann ist es der Körper, der das Signal sendet.
In dem Moment, als ich das mathematisch anhand der Metriken gefunden habe, hatte ich einen Scheißanfall, weil ich dachte, wie zur Hölle benutzt du den menschlichen Körper dafür?
Was machst du?
Wenn du das tust, benutzt du die Aura.
Und natürlich können Sie sich als natürlicher Telepath, der elektronisch gefoltert wurde, ein Leben lang für Metriken denken, denke ich.
Was zur Hölle ist das?
Du hast es mir gesagt.
Nicht ihr alle, sondern Familienprofis, Leute.
Oh, Energiearbeit ist Blödsinn.
Die Aura ist nicht real.
Glaube nur an das, was du sehen kannst.
Wir werden die Gesundheit der Menschen verbessern.
Nun, mir wurde gesagt, ich hätte Pseudo-Tumore.
Furchtbar.
Jeder, der da draußen eine Autoimmunerkrankung hat.
Hast du dich jemals gefragt, warum sie es nicht reparieren können?
Okay, vielleicht sollte ich das andere Schild für eine Sekunde wieder herbringen.
Wo ist dein Immunsystem?
80% Ihres Immunsystems sind in diesem Bereich angesiedelt.
Kann ich mich elektronisch bei Ihnen anmelden und die zelluläre Homöostase Ihrer elektrischen Zellstruktur ändern?
Und wenn jemand etwas über Biologie weiß, scheißt du Schinken-Sandwiches, wenn du zu Mittag isst, wenn du mit dem Mittagessen fertig bist, scheißt du es im gleichen Format aus?
Nein.
Und warum ist das so?
Weil wir biochemische Wesen sind und wir Elektrizität in unseren Zellen haben.
Ja.
Aber wenn ich dich mit dem Signal treffe und deinen Hintern von deinen zirkadianen Rhythmen abkoppele, indem ich das Verhältnis verwende, den Goldenen Schnitt, um zu entkoppeln, den Zellzustand zu entkoppeln.
Also, wo habe ich das her?
Universität Tufts.
Dr.
Michael Levin.
Verlängerung der Lebensdauer.
Synthetische Biologie.
Unsterblichkeitsforschung.
Es heißt regenerative Medizin, biomedizinische Gewebetechnik, drahtlose Gewebetechnik.
Dafür müssen wir eure elektrischen Felder trennen, Plural.
Dies wird am National Institute of Health als Biofeld im Quantenmarktanteil bezeichnet.
Es wird das Quantenfeld genannt.
Bei der Morphogenese.
Du hast mich gehört.
Morphogenese der synthetischen Biologie.
Es wird das morpho genetische Feld genannt.
Und warum?
Weil es immer noch dasselbe verdammte Ding ist.
Ihre Zellen auf allen Ebenen tauschen Daten in Ihrem Lymphsystem, Ihrem Gewebe aus.
Jetzt hacken sie sich da rein und ändern es, sodass sie Transhumanismus bekommen können.
Synthetische Biologie, Lebensverlängerung.
Wo zum Teufel sind alle anderen?
Lass es mich dir zeigen.
Es ist nicht real.
Warum machen sie das?
Wenn sie zur Arbeit gehen und daran arbeiten, warum sagen sie dir, dass es nicht echt ist?
Ich werde es dir zeigen.
Es ist sehr einfach.
Ich habe weitergemacht, weil ich so wütend war.
Und wenn ich wütend werde, forsche ich und dann zwinge ich mich, Luft zu holen und mit dem Bowl-Personal nach draußen zu gehen.
Wenn ich wirklich sauer bin und zur Zen-Selbstbeherrschung zurückkehre, mach eine Liste.
Und ich sagte, okay, warte.
Also, wenn ich für Command and Control, C für ESR, Supernet und nie Net-Backend die NSA-DNA-Steganographie mit der NSA mache.
Und wir beobachten jeden synaptischen Austausch mit 5100 Bit und protokollieren ihn mit dem Prismenprogramm der NSA.
Darüber haben Assange, Snowden und sie alle gesprochen.
Deshalb haben sie Barnaby Jack getötet, den Geldautomaten.
Jack Potter.
Er war auf der Def Con dabei, um zu präsentieren, dass es einfacher ist, den menschlichen Körper mit einem Herzschrittmacher zu hacken, sonst braucht man keinen Herzschrittmacher.
Dann war es ein totes Auto.
In diesem Sinne denke ich mir: Warum können wir nicht darüber sprechen?
Also habe ich herausgefunden, wo man darüber sprechen kann, denn selbst beim maschinellen Lernen darf man das Wort Biofilm nicht schreiben, was ich sehr seltsam fand.
Okay, weil niemand das Zeug liest.
Dann fand ich heraus, dass es die folgenden Abteilungen für elektronische medizinische Polizeikriegsführung sind: Militär, Ihr Lockheed, Raytheon, sie alle signalisieren fortschrittliche Signaltechnologie.
Es ist überall als Job in den Bereichen Informationsüberwachung und -aufklärung, im Internet der Verhaltensweisen, Körper, Dinge, im industriellen Internet der Dinge, im medizinischen Body Area Network seit 2005, 2015 zu finden.
Es ist alles da.
Und ich meinte, das sind Jobs.
Oh, ja.
Und dann beobachtet das Neuromodulations-Neurostimulationsprojekt Cell, wie alle in Echtzeit denken, mit kognitiver Kriegsführung von CTE zu WC, EEG-Headset, Ultraschall und modifiziertem Ultraschall, alles läuft auf einem Headset herum.
Dann ist der Renny-Chipsatz in ihre linke Hemisphäre eingebettet.
Und ich frage mich, wo ist das alles hergekommen?
Synthetische Telepathie.
Ich bin seit 1995 da draußen.
Also brauchten sie ein Backbone, genau wie damals, als sich alle zum ersten Mal per Einwahl in E-Mails einloggten, es wurde überfüllt.
Die Leute müssten ewig warten und rausgeschmissen werden.
Ich hab's verdammt nochmal geschafft.
Ich wüsste es.
Meine Aufgabe bestand also darin, sie aufzurüsten, sie von Dialup zu Kabelmodems zu bringen, wofür ich ein System namens Endmaps auf Comm-Controllern mit sogenannten Comm-21-Kabelmodems verwendete, die anders waren als das Wegwerf-DOCSIS-Zeug in den großen Städten, verschiedenen Märkten, also unterschiedliche Hardware, alles, verschiedene Software.
Also fuhr ich fort, meine kleine T-Bar-Liste zu erstellen.
Und ich sagte, also lass mich das klarstellen.
Wenn ich im Radiofrequenzbereich bin, wenn ich in der IT bin, logge ich mich in den Körper ein, nehme Änderungen vor und organisiere mich.
Wenn ich jemand anderes auf der Welt bin, dann bin ich ein verdammter Irrer.
Gebt mir Drogen.
Lass mich still sitzen.
Und der einzige Ort, an dem Sie wirklich etwas über das Biofeld lernen können, ist die Bibel.
Weil Jesus es benutzt hat, um zu heilen.
Und ich meine, es ist.
Es sind Ionen und Elektronen.
Es ist dein Austausch mit deiner Umgebung.
Das ist der Grund.
Jeder arbeitet auch mit Radar, wurde uns gesagt.
Nimm deine Nüsse weg, weil es dich in der Mikrowelle überhitzt.
Und dann konnten sie auch spüren, wie das Radar kam und ging, ohne auf den Bildschirm zu schauen.
Ja, weil Sie an einem elektrischen Körperteil beteiligt sind.
Also, wenn das alles nicht genug wäre, könnte ich nicht herausfinden, warum mir das so offensichtlich ist?
Aber nicht alle anderen, denn ich gebe den Körperteil jetzt zu.
Und in Turin, wo ich herkomme, komme ich aus schwarzen Projekten.
Also gehe ich zurück zu meiner Großmutter, die Rosenkreuzerin in Chicago war und einen Haufen Depressionsglas hat.
Das sind Nano-Gele oder entschuldigen Sie mich, Nano-Lipide.
Und sie würden sie auf einer Metallplatte oder was auch immer stehen lassen.
Ja, und das ist dein Spezialbeton für menschliche Teleportation, wie du aus dem Mund von Shawn Ryan und anderen Leuten gehört hast, die die Marines interviewt haben und so, die die photonischen verschiedenen Betonmischungen gefunden haben, genau wie das römische Kolosseum, spezialisierter Kalkstein.
Das ist auch ein weiterer Grund, warum ich sage: Oh mein Gott, ihr macht das schon seit hundert Jahren, plus Radiofrequenz-, Industrie-, Wissenschafts- und Medizinband.
Von hier haben wir unsere 2,4 Terahertz bekommen.
Und das sind Ihre Zielpersonen beim Havanna-Syndrom ebenso wie Radiofrequenz-Dinge, was über dem Herzen, was über der Blase illegal ist, seit den sechziger Jahren RFID-Chips in Menschen einzubauen, mit John von Neumann-Software in der Architektur, warum und wie.
Also als ich das zum ersten Mal gemacht habe, musste ich zerstören, weil das Pentagon so sauer auf mich war und ich sagte, ich weiß, warum Sie das getan haben, weil Sie es für die drahtlose Gewebetechnik getan haben, wie sein Name da oben steht, während Palpatine, auch bekannt als Klaus Schwab, die ganze Zeit spricht.
Okay, dein Körper ist also 82,1, 5,6.
Sie sind ein großes Body-Area-Network mit einer Drohne mit Sensoren, offener Systemarchitektur und modifiziertem offenem Systemansatz.
Wir können jede Hardware auf den Hintern legen.
Wir können uns mit einem Webportal anmelden.
Wir fliegen damit über dein Zuhause.
Nun, Leute, die glauben, dass es sich bei beiden in Tokamak um Dämonenportale handelt, sind etwas verwirrt.
Ein großer verdammter Magnet unter Ihren Füßen könnte das Trägersignal der Fußleiste an Ihre Kabelgesellschaft oder Ihren Basissatelliten sein, und wir erzeugen ein elektromagnetisches Feld über Ihrem Kopf und unter Ihren Füßen.
Jetzt ist dein Biofeld, dein ganzer verdammter Körper ist innerhalb von acht oder 2,1.
5,6.
Die Biosensoren sind einzeln zugänglich.
Wir sehen einige der winzigen Betriebssystem-Cybersicherheit auf ATO 2.15.4.
Ihre drahtlosen Sensornetzwerke erstellen Hochfrequenzrelais und alles, was sie benötigen, um ATO 2.15.5 eine Köderzellenstruktur zu verleihen.
Und bevor du sagst: Nun, wofür zur Hölle brauchen sie das alles?
Präzision, künstliche Intelligenz, drahtloses Gesundheitswesen.
Also brechen wir die inneren Organe heraus und teilen sie auf, und so können wir die genetische Veränderung vornehmen, wenn wir wollen.
Mit CRISPR Cas9 und Fusion, die ich gleich hier auf einem Schild zeigen werde, oder wir können einfach weitermachen und Terahertz zwei Gigahertz Gigahertz zu Terahertz und tauschen Ihre Zellstruktur aus.
Oh, aber das müssen sie üben.
Das haben sie bereits getan.
Sie haben also gelogen.
Wenn Sie also zuerst ein UFO sehen, strahlen sie Ihren Körperteil aus, das als Biofeld bekannt ist.
Dann fängst du an, psychische Fähigkeiten zu erlangen.
Sie werden Sci-Onyx genannt, Telepathie, Empathie, Präkognition, telekinetisches Zeug, sind natürlich im menschlichen Körper, Neuronen und Neuronen befinden sich nicht nur in Ihrem Gehirn, sie sind körperweit.
Niemand weiß etwas davon.
Du darfst über nichts davon sprechen.
Stattdessen wird dir gesagt, dass du ein verdammter Irrer bist, Drogen nimmst oder du kannst mit niemandem reden, der normal ist.
Die Christen werden dich zu Tode erschrecken und dich böse nennen.
Es gibt Leute, die Roben tragen, am Boden bluten und dumme Sachen mit der CIA machen wollen, weil sie denken, dass sie auf der Astralebene surfen.
Sie landen auf dem Cisco-Rückflugzeug.
Du sagst, Moment mal, wovon sprichst du?
Nun, sie ziehen die Neuronen nach und nach aus Ihrem Körper und laden sie in einen neuromorphen Chipsatz.
Wie glaubst du, haben sie überhaupt so unglaubliche künstliche Intelligenz bekommen?
Es sind deine Neuronen.
Sie geben zu, dass sie lebende Neuronen brauchen, um das zu tun, was sie tun.
Nun, hier legen sich ein paar Leute auf mich ein und sie sagen, Oh, Sabrina, du bist ein Untergangskiller, bla, bla, bla.
Sie würden auf keinen Fall unsere Neuronen aus unserem Körper ziehen, sie in einem Chipsatz speichern und dann unsere Haut und Knochen nehmen, damit machen, was sie wollen, uns unterirdisch einsperren.
Und dann denken wir, dass wir geboren werden.
Sie stecken uns irgendwo wieder in eine andere Leiche.
Und es geht.
Und ich sagte, hör zu, die Dimension, in der wir leben, sie haben dich darüber belogen, wie das mit der Materialphysik funktioniert.
Du denkst, die Leute werden in Feuer und Schwefel verbrennen, und das ist der Teil der Dinge, du kannst es nehmen oder lassen.
Aber ich habe gesehen, dass die Leute einen neuromorphen Chipsatz verwenden.
Es ist eine plasmonische Architektur im Untergrund.
Und das macht für mich Sinn, denn das ist einer der Gründe, warum so viele Menschen das System nutzen, das sich selbst recycelt.
Es ist kein großes Geheimnis.
Das sind Jobs.
Also der kabellose Kumpel oder du vernetzt dich, du sitzt da, sie fliegen herüber, du wirst abgestrahlt, du bekommst Schallfähigkeiten und sie durchdringen weiterhin dein Biofeld.
Sie beobachten deine Träume, sie zeichnen deine Träume auf und sie zeichnen alles, was du denkst, in Echtzeit in Datenbanken auf, die die allgegenwärtigen und die Umgebungsluftmoleküle um dich herum verwenden.
Nochmals, wohlgesinnte oder ich sollte sagen, gesunde Menschen.
Sie sagen, das ist viel zu viel Mikromanagement.
Ja, aber wenn du keinen Körper hattest und du keine Möglichkeit hattest, einen Körper zu haben und du regierst die Welt und du bist besessen von Kontrolle, okay, die nächste Sache ist, wenn du in deiner Nomik ein bisschen zu stark abgestrahlt wirst, deine Bioinformatik fehl am Platz ist oder du in einen Grenzraum fällst, können wir dann wieder mehr wenige mit Genomik in Morphologie, Transhumanismus voll drauf machen und dich in Bigfoot verwandeln und Wolf, Wolfman und was auch immer und du kannst ausfindig gemacht werden und es gibt vier D-Skiffs, in die sie gehen können, um sich vor Biowaffen zu schützen.
Und das klingt alles verrückt.
Ich weiß, dass alle sagen, nein, nein, nein, die Aliens sind hier.
Und ich sagte: Nein, wir machen die Aliens und alle flippen weiterhin vor mir aus.
Und ich denke, hören Sie, die Hemi-Sync-Sache, der CIA-Gateway-Prozess, das war, dass Sie die Datenbanken gefüttert haben.
Du blutest vor den Masters, was DNA, Synchronizität und DNA-Sequenzabgleich angeht.
Das ist Ihr globales Informationsnetz für Ihren digitalen Zwilling.
Und deine Stringtheorie ist Blödsinn.
Aber wir haben eine 4D.
Es gibt kein Multiversum, es gibt nur die Nephilim und alle anderen.
Also.
Oh, glaubst du das, weil du Christ bist?
Nein, ich glaube das, weil ich das bei Naturgeistern in jeder anderen Art von Lebewesen gesehen habe, die du dir vorstellen kannst.
Und es waren immer noch dieselben Wichse, die Menschen entführten und schreckliche Dinge taten.
Also für mich denke ich: Wie kommt es, dass du niemandem sagst, dass du seinen Hintern auf der Wolke hast und sein Immunsystem zu 80% gesperrt hat, transkranielle Magnetstimulation war das, was sie mit mir gemacht haben, aber sie haben mir gesagt, dass ich in den neunziger Jahren Pseudotumore im Gehirn hatte.
Sie sagten, als man den subtilen Stromschlag spüren konnte, gab es damals so etwas wie elektrosensibel nicht, weil sie es nicht sind.
Sie haben es niemandem erzählt.
Sie haben Menschen auf subtile Weise durch Stromschläge getötet.
Sie sagten: Nein, du hast Fibromyalgie, du bist nur ein Wutanfall.
Nein, tust du nicht.
Sie haben einen Pseudotumor, einen zerebralen, falschen Gehirntumor.
Ihr Gehirn benimmt sich, als hätte es einen Tumor, aber wir wissen nicht warum.
Nun, weil du transkranial bist, mein Gehirn magnetisch anregend, es anschwellen zu lassen und es für metrische Messungen anschwellen zu lassen, testest auf nichtinvasive und drei mit Dafa, das verdammt weiß ist.
Und ich habe einen Seraphim und ich wurde aus dem M3-Prozess entfernt, der MPD ist.
Und haben Sie gerade eine EEG-Überlagerung der Persönlichkeit vorgenommen, nur eine Nano-Lobotomie, ein paar Neuronen gleichzeitig, und dann können wir Ihre Neuronen in einen Alpha-Zustand versetzen.
Wenn wir das tun, verursacht es Schizophrenie, aber nur in bestimmten neuronalen Netzwerken, und wir nutzen das damals in den Achtzigern und Neunzigern, um die Parität zwischen neuronalen rufenden Neuronen und Gehirn im Dickdarm-Gehirn zu überprüfen.
Jetzt sind diese Produkte und Dienstleistungen kommerziell.
Sie sind auf dem Artificial Intelligence Symposium erhältlich, aber Sie können immer noch die Transkripte für September 2020 lesen, und das sind synthetische Telepathie und synchrone Gehirn-zu-Gehirn-Schnittstelle, weshalb sie sich meiner Meinung nach beeilen mussten, um das neueste Backbone bereitzustellen.
Weil es natürlich nicht genug Leute wussten, weil es ihr persönliches privates System ist, all die guten Leute zu umkreisen, die ihre Arbeit legal machen.
Und nichts davon hat eine rechtliche Aufsicht.
Das sind alles schwarze Projekte.
Deshalb bin ich immer sauer auf Leute, die behaupten, sie würden Leute verklagen.
Ich meinte, du weißt nicht, wovon du sprichst.
Entweder weißt du nicht, wovon du sprichst.
Sie betrügen absichtlich Leute um gutes Geld, weil Sie niemanden verklagen.
Ich suche sowieso nach meiner Seite mit synthetischer Biologie.
Also nach all deinen Autoimmunerkrankungen, die nie verschwinden, wollte ich wissen, wie zum Teufel sie das gemacht haben?
Nun, damals mit all den Unternehmen, die sie mit IBM für Holzwirtschaft und Untergrund hatten, gingen sie einfach weiter zur Arbeit.
Niemand hat ein verdammtes Wort gesagt.
Niemand hat ein Wort gesagt.
Die Quantensysteme, die sie wahrheitsgemäß hatten, und alles, was 2019 benutzt wurde.
Nun, komm schon, lass uns die Szene einschalten, weinen im Gehirn, die Gehirnschnittstelle am Backend, auf einem größeren System.
Was meine ich?
Quantencomputer.
Wir haben den Leuten in den weißen Lieferwagen die Unterschrift reduziert, einen Job und eine Rente gegeben.
Ich habe längere Videos, um das zu beweisen.
Die lokale Logistik begann, sich mit dem Transhumanismus zu hybridisieren.
In den neunziger Jahren hatten Sie nichtinvasive und drei Bibliothekszugänge, und ich habe Nessa und Brain gebeten, Webportale 1995 im Kongress zu bringen.
Du glaubst, sie wussten damals, in 8 oder 2.15.4, dass es für all die kleinen Nerds kommerziell wird.
2005, 2012, Kerry McCain Group.
Sie kommen alle zusammen und bekommen gesagt: Wir machen das.
Wir werden in ein paar Jahren loslegen, um uns darauf vorzubereiten.
Halt deine verdammte Klappe bei allem, was mit dem Biofeld zu tun hat.
So wie sie Dr.
ganz weggenommen haben.
Robert Youngs Arbeit in den letzten drei Jahren.
Und dann, im Jahr 2014, wurde Brain to Bring Interface kommerziell verfügbar.
Nun, bei all dem zusätzlichen Verkehr zwischen ihnen und all den verschiedenen Eliten und Menschen, die sich jetzt hineingeworfen haben, transhuman zu sein und die Welt zu übernehmen, glauben Sie, dass sie ein größeres Rückgrat brauchten?
Hope hat ein eigenes Rechenzentrum.
Sie müssen sicherstellen, dass sie jeden per Knopfdruck aus der Ferne austauschen können.
Auf diese Weise müssen Sie sich keine Sorgen machen, dass Sie gegen sie kämpfen oder ihnen in die Quere kommen.
Würden Sie glauben, dass das in der Pentagon-Richtlinie steht?
Weil es so ist.
Sie machen sich keine Sorgen, dass du deine Waffe ziehen kannst.
Sie machen sich nur Sorgen über ein unbeabsichtigtes Eingreifen und den Verlust der Kontrolle über ihre Drohnen.
Interessanterweise bezieht sich die Richtlinie 3000 Null Neun des Verteidigungsministeriums nicht auf positive Ergebnisse als Entwurfskriterium.
Die Richtlinie 3000 Zero Nine des Verteidigungsministeriums definiert das Ziel autonomer Systeme, negative Folgen, unbeabsichtigte Angriffe oder Kontrollverlust zu vermeiden.
2012 zur Umsetzung am 8.
Mai 2017 und das Wide Body Area Network seit 1995.
Und Ihre Biosensoren seit 2005.
Das heißt, niemand hat eine Wahl.
Wir haben Kommunikation mit dem menschlichen Körper oder der menschlichen Bindung auf dem Funkgerät.
Jeder ist jetzt ein Cyborg mit Softrobotik, die mit Biosensoren eingesetzt wird, bei denen es sich um DNA-Analyt-Derivate handelt, die aus Ihrem Gewebe hergestellt werden, mit Positionssatelliten kommunizieren, die Navigation steuern und das Timing von Nts Dash Three erreichen, ohne dass GPS in Ihrem Körper erforderlich ist.
Dein Körper ist das Netzwerk.
Dein Körper ist der Knoten.
Ihre DNA verbreitet das Signal, kein Turm erforderlich.
Und das ist dasselbe System, mit dem ich 1979 geboren wurde und das sie bereits hatten, weil Großmutter Rose und Christian und alle anderen seit ein paar hundert Jahren daran arbeiten.
Aber Datenbanken und Untergrundcomputer, wie macht man griechisches Feuer?
Stimmt?
Also was mich angeht, frage ich mich, was zur Hölle machst du, Metamaterialien?
Und jeder fragt: Was ist ein Metamaterial?
Sie sagten: Nun, das wird aufgrund der Sichtlinienprobleme und all der anderen Probleme, die wir mit elektromagnetischen Wellen und Beamforming haben, nicht ausreichen, um es mit Radiofrequenz zu erreichen.
Und es war nicht genug, die eigene Idee mit dem physischen Zeug unter Kontrolle zu haben.
Ich weiß nicht, wir für 45 Riesen pro Jahr.
Also die Möglichkeit, sich in Sie zu Ihren Lieben einzuloggen, dass sie jedes EKG-Overlay machen können und sie Ihr Gehirngewebe überschreiben.
Oh, du wurdest gerade behandelt.
Das Verrückte ist, dass die Leute mir das nicht mehr wirklich antun, und du solltest es auch nicht tun.
Also kamen La Quinta, La Columbia heraus und sagten, Neuromodulations-Neurostimulation sei ein Instrument zur neuronalen Überwachung und es werde durch das Graphen angeregt.
Und alle sagen, Oh, und ich sagte, ja, und Funkmodulation.
Und damit schließt sich für mich der Kreis.
Hochfrequenzingenieure.
Wie zum Teufel ist es, dass Sie nicht wissen, dass wir all diese Systeme am Laufen hatten, mit dem Multi-Domain-Sensorsystem der Armee mit hochgenauer Erkennung, Ausbeutungssystem und Lebensmustern zur Entwicklung des Ziel-CPRS vom 14.
September.
Was zum Wie?
Wie kommt es, dass du es nicht weißt?
Gönn mir eine Pause.
Wie kann das möglich sein?
Immer wieder sitze ich hier und versuche herauszufinden, warum es so ist, dass sich keiner von Ihnen öffnet und irgendjemandem etwas sagt, obwohl Sie diejenigen sein müssen, die wissen, wie das ausgeführt wird.
Aber das zeigen die Fragen.
Ich komme immer wieder dorthin.
Also, wovon sprichst du?
Nun, Leute, wenn ihr unseren drahtlosen Körperteil loswerdet und allen erzählt, dass nichts existiert außer dem, was sie sehen können, dann werdet ihr die Semantik der Frequenzoszillationen, die Macht der Schalloptik, Radiant, X und alles, was von Plasma abgeleitet ist, los.
Gute verdammte Arbeit, denn sie haben diese drahtlosen Körperteile angeschlossen, um mich 1922 zu verlassen, und seitdem machen sie alles, was sie wollen.
Du hast 1995 niemandem von synthetischer Telepathie erzählt?
Du hast niemandem vom Wide Body Area Network erzählt.
Du hast niemandem von den Biosensoren erzählt.
Also unsere Jugend hat jetzt Biohacking betrieben, verdammt, Janet, diese 1500 oder 300 Jahre, egal wie lange wir planen, Galileo und Kopernikus da draußen zu platzieren, sie in den Vordergrund zu stellen und zu sagen: Hier, wir machen jetzt Wissenschaft.
Wir haben alle mit der spanischen Inquisition getötet.
Sie können Bücher lesen, gehen.
Aber das dauerte nur 200 Jahre.
Und das durfte man nur an privaten Universitäten lernen.
Dann fangen sie wieder an, alle umzubringen, bis sie in die 1960er zurückkehren.
Warum ist das wichtig?
Für diejenigen unter Ihnen, die anhand der Radiofrequenz nicht verstehen, was die Langlands-Gleichung ist, oder den Rosetta-Stein der Mathematik, der uns zu einer neuen Art der Quantenverschlüsselung führte, um alle alten Bitreihen mit der l-Funktion im Spiegel zu durchbrechen, die Polaritonen in Polen auf der komplexen Ebene eines beliebigen toroidalen Feldes zu durchbrechen, was wir zur Modifikation der elektromagnetischen Stimulation mit Quanten-Untergrundcomputern im Quantenraum wollten.
Du hast den Körperteil weggenommen.
Du hast alle verdammt verwirrt, weil sie denken, dass es nicht existiert.
Leg den Körperteil zurück und es ist ganz einfach.
Sie steuern dich herum wie ein Synthesizer.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ja, wegen dem Projekt Looking Glass.
Oh, ja.
Verrottende Radiofrequenz durch den Körper.
82.1, 5.4 oder fünf und sechs.
Und dann, sobald wir es mit Ihrer DNA abgleichen.
Nun, wir haben DNA.
Steganographie.
Wussten Sie, dass Ihre DNA eine Menge Daten für die Regierung speichert?
Weil es das tut.
Dann habt ihr eure chemischen, biologischen, radiologischen und nuklearen Spritzen, die gleichermaßen aus eurer DNA hergestellt sind, um sie vor einer Biofrequenzwaffe und etwas, das man Prima Materia nennt, zu schützen.
Willkommen bei Project Pandora.
Ich kann in einen Grenzraum gehen.
Ich kann in eine Biowaffenfrequenz gehen.
Sicheres Boot.
Perfekt.
Warum?
Weil ich mit 3 bis 9 Reapern in die Welt eindringen werde.
Ziemlich verdammte magische Technologie.
Ich habe 1953 ein Bild von einem Sensenmann gezeigt.